.
>> THAT IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
LEYLA SANTIAGO, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>>> NEW DATA FROM THE CDC AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENTS WILL BE OF CONCERN
TO PARENTS.
THE FEDERAL AGENCIES SAY THAT
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN IN THE
HOSPITAL WITH COVID-19 IS
GETTING CLOSE TO A PEAK THAT WAS
REACHED IN EARLY SEPTEMBER.
NEW YORK CITY IS REPORTING A
FIVE FOLD INCREASE IN PEDIATRIC
HOSPITALIZATIONS.
OUR CNN SENIOR MEDICAL
CORRESPONDENT ELIZABETH COHEN IS
FOLLOWING ALL OF THIS FOR US.
SO WHAT SHOULD PARENTS KNOW
ABOUT THIS INCREASE IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR CHILDREN?
>> I THINK THE FIRST THING THEY
SHOULD KNOW IS THAT STILL THE
THUMB OF CHILDNUMBER OF CHILDRE
HOSPITAL IN THE U.S. IS STILL
VERY SMALL, COUNT  BU, COUNTED
COUPLE HUNDRED ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES.
BUT THE CONCERN IS THAT THE
NUMBERS ARE RISING, STILL A
SMALL NUMBER, BUT THEY ARE
RISING.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT NATIONAL
NUMBERS.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS THAT IF YOU
LOOK AT COVID-19
HOSPITALIZATIONS AMONG CHILDREN,
FOR THE WEEKENDING DECEMBER
18th, IT WAS 201 PER DAY.
THE WEEKENDING DECEMBER 25th,
260 PER DAY.
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT JUMP.
STILL A SMALL NUMBER, BUT A
SIGNIFICANT JUMP.
NOW LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT ONE
CITY, NEW YORK CITY, WHICH HAS
BEEN HIT SO HARD RECENTLY.
FROM DECEMBER 5 THROUGH THE
11th, THEY HAD 22 ADMISSIONS,
AND THEN DECEMBER 19 THROUGH 23,
SHORTER TIME PERIOD, THEY HAD
109 ADMISSIONS.
THAT IS A BIG JUMP.
PART OF WHAT MIGHT BE GOING ON
HERE IS THAT OMICRON IS SO
TRANSMISSIBLE, SO MANY MORE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING INFECTED,
THAT YOU ARE GOING TO SEE MORE
CHILDREN ENDING UP IN THE
HOSPITAL.
SO FAR THE NUMBERS AREN'T HUGE,
BUT THE RISE IS CERTAINLY OF
CONCERN.
>> YEAH, SO NO REASON TO PANIC,
BUT CERTAINLY A REASON TO PAY
ATTENTION.
ELIZABETH COHEN, THANK YOU.
>>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S BRING IN DR. PAUL OFFITT
FROM CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL OF
PHILADELPHIA AND MEMBER OF THE
FDA VACCINE ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS TOER CLOO UP
HERE.
ON THE ONE HAND, THIS IS
GUIDANCE SHIFTING THAT YOU HAD
SAID WAS IDEAL, WAS NECESSARY.
AND NOW IT IS IN PLACE.
BUT THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE, HOW MUCH OF IT IS
BASED ON THE DATA AND HOW MUCH
OF IT IS BASED ON THE NEED OF
EMPLOYERS AMID THIS OMICRON
WAVE?
>> I THINK THAT IT IS FAIR.
I MEAN, WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT HOW
INFECTIONS WORK INCLUDING THIS
INFECTION, THE VIRUS SORT OF
ATTACHES TO YOUR NOSE AND THROAT
AND BEGINS TO REPRODUCE ITSELF
HUNDREDS OF TIMES, THOUSANDS OF
TIMES.
THAT IS WHEN YOU ARE MOST
CONTAGIOUS.
AND THEN YOU DEVELOP SYMPTOMS
AND THOSE SYMPTOMS ARE BASED ON
YOUR IMMUNE RESPONSE.
THAT IS WHAT CAUSES THE
SYMPTOMS.
SO NOW YOU HAVE SYMPTOMS.
AND AS THE SYMPTOMS COME UP,
THEN VIRAL REPLICATION DECREASES
DRAMATICALLY.
BY THE TIME THAT YOU HAVE NO
SYMPTOMS, IT WOULD BE FAIR TO
SAY THAT YOU ARE SHREDDING VERY
TRIVIAL VIRUS IF ANY AT ALL.
SO IF YOU ARE ASYMPTOMATIC, I
THINK IT IS FAIR THAT YOU CAN
BREAK QUARANTINE AND I THINK
THAT IS CONSERVATIVE.
SO I THINK THIS IS PER ABOUT
EF
PERFECTLY REASONABLE.
>> THE KEY PART IS IF YOU ARE
ASYMPTOMATIC.
OF COURSE WHEN THE NEWS WAS
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY WERE
SHORTENING THIS, THAT WAS THE
KEY PHRASE THAT PEOPLE MAY HAVE
MISSED BUT NEEDED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO.
SO DO YOU THINK THAT PEOPLE WILL
BE HONEST ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE ASYMPTOMATIC AND GOING
BACK INTO THEIR DAILY LIVES?
>> NO.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE PRETTY MUCH
FOUND OVER THE PAST YEAR THAT
THE TRUST SYSTEM, THE HONOR HIM
IS SYSTEM, DOESN'T SEEM TO WORK
VERY WELL.
I THINK THAT YOU COULD SIMPLIFY
IT BY SAYING IF YOU ARE SICK
WAIT UNTIL YOU ARE NOT SICK AND
THEN PLEASE WEAR A MASK.
AND IF YOU HAVE BEEN EXPOSED, AT
LEAST WEAR A MASK FOR TEN DAYS.
WE'VE TRIED TO DIVIDE IT UP TO
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED AS
COMPARED TO UNVACCINATED OR NOT
BOOSTED.
BUT PROBABLY EASIER TO REMEMBER
WEAR A MASK FOR TEN DAYS IF YOU
KNOW THAT YOU'VE BEEN EXPOSED.
>> AND THE FACT THAT THE HONOR
SYSTEM HAS BROKEN TOWNDOWN IS AL
PROBLEM.
SO WHAT ABOUT GUIDANCE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE VACCINATED VERSUS
UNVACCINATED?
HAS THAT CHANGED AT ALL?
SHOULD IT?
>> SO WHAT THEY HAVE TRIED TO
SAY IS THAT IF YOU ARE
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED, THEN YOU
ONLY HAVE TO WEAR A MASK, DON'T
WORRY ABOUT QUARANTINING IF YOU
ARE EXPOSED.
BUT IF YOUBOOSTED OR
NOT VACCINATED, YOU STILL HAVE
TO QUARANTINE FOR FIVE DAYS IF
EXPOSED.
IT IS HARD TO REMEMBER ALL THAT.
WHAT THE EASIEST THING TO
REMEMBER, THAT MASKING.
I THINK THAT MASKING IS GOING TO
BE THE KEY FOR ABOUT THE NEXT
SIX WEEKS.
WE'LL BE DEALING WITH THIS VIRUS
IN A MAJOR WAY FOR THE NEXT SIX
WEEKS.
FIRST OF ALL, IT IS WINTER.
YOU WILL SEE AN INCREASE IN
CASES AND HOSPITALIZATIONS
ANYWAY EVEN IF OMICRON WASN'T
HERE.
PLUS YOU HAVE OMICRON WHICH IS
MUCH MORE CONTAGIOUS.
AND YOU HAVE A VIRUS WHICH IS
SLIGHTLY OFF TARGET FROM
IMMUNITY INDUCED BY VACCINE IN
TERMS OF LOCATION GETS MILD
DISEASE.
THAT WILL PROTECT YOU FROM
SEVERE DISEASE, BUT NOT AS WELL
AGAINST MILD DISEASE.
AS DR. FAUCI SAID, THERE WILL BE
A LOT OF ASYMPTOMATIC OR MILDLY
SYMPTOMATIC INFECTIONS.
A FLOOD OF THAT.
BUT THIS VIRUS, WHERE IT WILL
HIT HARD IS PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNVACCINATED.
AND IN OUR HOSPITAL FOR EXAMPLE,
WHAT WE DO, ANYTIME A CHILD IS
ADMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL, WE
TEST THEM TO SEE WHETHER THEY
HAVE COVID.
THERE IS CLEARLY AN INCREASE IN
THAT NUMBER.
BUT WHAT THERE IS NOT AN
INCREASE THIS IS CHILDREN WHO
ARE HOSPITALIZED BECAUSE THEY
HAVE COVID.
SO THERE IS A DISASSOCIATION
BETWEEN CASES AND SERIOUS CASES.
>> THAT IS GOOD NEWS FOR
PARENTS.
ONE THING THAT SURPRISED ME WHEN
THE NEW CDC GUIDANCE CAME OUT
YESTERDAY IS THEY DID NOT
RECOMMEND THAT PEOPLE TAKE A ARE
A PID TESRAPID TEST BEFORE ENDIR
ISOLATION PERIOD.
AND THAT CAN OFTEN BE A GOOD WAY
TO KNOW IF YOU ARE STILL HIGHLY
CONTAGIOUS.
WHY DO YOU THINK THE CDC DIDN'T
TAKE THAT STEP YESTERDAY?
>> IF PEOPLE ARE HONEST AND THEY
TRULY HAVE NO SYMPTOMS, THE
CHANCE THAT THEY ARE SHEDDING AN
AMOUNT OF VIRUS THAT WOULD CAUSE
THEM TO BE LIKELY CONTAGIOUS IS
EXTREMELY SMALL.
NOT ZERO, BUT SMALL.
SO ALSO IT IS HARD TO GET TESTS.
SO I THINK THAT MAY BE PART OF
IT AS WELL.
BUT AGAIN, IT IS THE HONOR
SYSTEM.
YOU REALLY DO HAVE TO BE
ASYMPTOMATIC AND THAT WORRIES
ME.
>> I WANT TO JUST FOCUS ON THE
DATA.
THERE ARE NUMBERS THAT SHOULD
GET PEOPLE'S ATTENTION ABOUT THE
REALTY OF WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH.
INSIDE IS LAST WEEK, WE'VE SEEN
A 61.5% INCREASE IN NEW CASES.
A 17.8 INCREASE IN NEW DEATHS.
A DECREASE OF 33.4% IN THE
NUMBER OF VACCINES ADMINISTERED.
THAT DECREASE IN VACCINES
ADMINISTERED IS SIMPLY INSANE TO
ME.
BUT DO YOU THINK THIS NEW
GUIDANCE THAT DECREASES
ISOLATION TIME FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
ASYMPTOMATIC WILL HELP RATHER
THAN HURT THOSE INDICATORS?
>> WELL, IN A BETTER WORLD,
SURE.
IN A BETTER WORLD PEOPLE WOULD
BE FRIGHTENED ENOUGH BY OMICRON
AND CARE ENOUGH ABOUT THEIR OWN
HEALTH AND THE HEALTH OF THE
PEOPLE THEY COME IN CONTACT WITH
TO BE VACCINATED.
OBVIOUSLY WHAT WE DEAL WITH IN
THE HOSPITAL WHEN WE SEE
CHILDREN HOSPITALIZED BECAUSE OF
COVID, THEY ARE ALL
UNVACCINATED.
PARENTS ARE UNVACCINATED.
SIBLINGS ARE UNVACCINATED.
ANYBODY WHO CARES ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH OR PEOPLE WITH WHOM THEY
COME IN CONTACT WITH WILL GET
VACCINATED.
AND PEOPLE WHO -- I'D LIKE TO
SEE A STUDY ON WHO IS GETTING
TESTED.
I IMAGINE PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING
TESTED CARE ABOUT THEIR HEALTH,
CARE ABOUT PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE
COMING IN CONTACT WITH AND
THEREFORE MORE LIKELY TO BE
VACCINATED.
BUT INTERESTING TO SEE THOSE
DATA.
>> IT WOULD BE INTERESTING.
BUT THE THING IS, IT IS SO HARD
TO GET TESTS THAT IT IS HARD TO
GET PEOPLE INTO THAT REGULAR
TESTING ROUTINE NOW THAT THEY
ARE SEEKING THEM OUT, IF YOU
HAVE TO GO TO MULTIPLE STORES,
IT IS NOT ENCOURAGING TO TAKE A
TEST.
AND I DO WANT TO ASK, WHEN DO
YOU THINK THAT THIS WILL PEAK?
WHEN WILL WE SEE THE PEAK OF
THIS OMICRON WAVE HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES?
>> I'D BE SURPRISED IF WE
WEREN'T DRAMATICALLY COMING OFF
OF THIS BY LATE FREB.
LAST WINTER WE DIDN'T HAVE MANY
PEOPLE VACCINATED OR EVEN
NATURALLY INFECTED AND WE WERE
COMING DOWN IN MID-FEBRUARY.
AND I THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE
TRUE HERE AND MAYBE EARLIER THAN
THAT.
SO WE JUST NEED TO GET THROUGH
THE NEXT SIX WEEKS.
VACCINATE YOURSELF.
AND IF YOU HAVE BEEN EXPOSED,
PLEASE WEAR A MASK AT LEAST FOR